is this
really the best we have to offer or is
the system so broken
that the best and brightest are excluded
from political leadership
because responsible conscientious
ethical people are eliminated early on
or
simply can't afford the outrageous
budget required to compete as
a candidate here's my pithy answer for
you all and then i'll let you unpack it
here
a corrupt system does not make room for
the truth uh my pithy answer is she was
right
tweet that this is not the best we have
well
yeah i mean the system blocks out
like we have heard from people who have
like andrew yang tulsi gabber right they
made a lot of noise on social media
because they were going against party
orthodoxy
and what happened they're russian agents
right instead of
even if i don't agree with everything
tulsi uh
says even if i don't agree with anything
andrew yang says they're both saying
things that are kind of different
and that's cool and what if we like
apply like what if biden took yang's
universal income
what if uh uh uh another democrat
was like yeah tulsi is kind of right we
were the anti-war party
why are we suddenly you know what i'm
saying like there are ways that we
should be able to take from these voices
or
i mean again back to nader like they
didn't let homeboy in the debate
they learned with ross perot this is
what happens when you get
a third voice in the debate and it kind
of shakes things up and we don't like it
and the establishment wants to keep
things establishment so she's kind of
right
yeah i don't know when i see things like
unity 2020 getting
uh you know muted on twitter i mean it's
are you guys familiar with the
university 2020 thing no no no i'm not
it's the it's what um which weinstein i
always forget which one it
eric yeah what's one of them
[Music]
not harvey one of the weinstein brothers
started this
this movement where it's you take a
candidate from the republican side and a
candidate from the democratic side and
you create a unity ticket
and then one and they do a coin toss to
decide which one is president which
one's vice
and then at the end of the four years if
they win then they have to reverse roles
so i think this year it was dan crenshaw
and tulsi gabbard
were the two picks so tulsi from the
democratic side and dan crenshaw from
the republican and then
they would form this unity ticket the
idea is that then
this would unify america that these
would be candidates that people could
get behind
and that people would realize that we
don't live in such a polarized two-party
system
it's kind of a way to oh and uh one of
the um
important aspects of it is getting on
the ballot because ballot access is a
real problem for third parties
and so what the unity 2020 movement was
going to do was try to get
um the libertarian party actually has
more ballot access in more states than
green
but green does have some 20-something
states that they're on the
ballot for so unity 2020's idea was then
to go and petition
um basically libertarian or green party
in each state
to try to get on the ballot for them
yeah to be the candidates for their
for their i think libertarian would be
more likely to do it but i don't
green has got some issues going on
internally right now i'm not sure if
they would but
it's a good idea not sure if it would
actually work in
practice and you also obviously you need
a lot of money and just
to the question money it takes money
and i think this just goes to show that
money cannot buy anything
right right like a really good candidate
man how gross is it whenever you see how
much like
the mainstream democrats or republicans
spent
and you just think about how many people
we could have fed with that
you know especially right now i know i
know and it's just it's
just to get a bunch of just to get two
candidates that no one's happy with
hey maybe maybe it actually takes a lot
of money to get a bad candidate
um
yeah you can tweet that podcast on yeah
that's good go ahead though
although it's fashionable to say people
are stupid i don't think people are
stupid no
i think people know when someone's lying
to them or not
people know when somebody's speaking
straight and
in order to suppress the truth in order
to prevent people from discovering the
truth
it takes a heck of a lot of effort to
drown out the voice of truth
right um it was i believe it was g.k
chesterton who spoke of the truth being
so dangerous that
it has to be surrounded by a bodyguard
of lies
and so one of the ways that you push the
voices of truth
who call out the corruption in the
system right
who who say the things that we're
uncomfortable hearing and saying
ourselves
you you drown them out you you put a
price tag on everything and you say hey
you got to have this much money if you
even want to participate in the debate
right think about how much money is
spent just in keeping
certain voices from even participating
in debates yeah
so that we can't see biden or trump
being challenged by a different way of
thinking
i think i think it takes a lot of money
to keep the poor people in there
incompetent people that's a great point
it's interesting how bloomberg
bought his way into the like if you have
you know if you have enough money to
know the right people you can buy your
way into the debates i mean it's
to go nowhere yeah no one wanted
blueberries so much money
it goes even beyond that once you're in
you know for example congress
once you're in congress and you've been
elected then it takes money to get on
the committee seats so to become speaker
of the house that's not because the
person you know is the best leader
from that party that is not the reason
why they're speaker of the house they're
speaker of the house because they raised
the most money
and that is well known inside of
congress on both sides they do this if
you want to be on
the top committee then you have to raise
a certain amount of money and give that
money back to the party
and it's actually printed out they're
handed this saying if this is the
committee seating you if you want this
assignment
this is what it's going to cost you and
then by the way they leave office they
become lobbyists
right they're all these jobs make a ton
of money then they go back
campaign with their friends who are
still in office and it's like it's money
money money we don't learn our lesson to
quote britney spears oops i did it again
answer is this focus less on government
and more on contributing beyond yourself
in a meaningful way and this makes you
think about what you were saying cam
about looking
through it uh trying to put yourself in
someone else's shoes
because ultimately what that leads us to
do is show compassion and i think that
is what america is lacking right now and
personally i would much rather people
go out of their way to show compassion
than go vote so that's the one exception
where i'll be like
voting isn't as important as showing
compassion